with the Venezuelan opposition blaming
the government for severe food shortages
one investigative journalist in Caracas
says not all is as it seems
max Blumenthal went to a supermarket and
this is what he found I feel lost in the
supermarket this is Jesus there's a lot
of cheeses and meats here fish heads
fish heads roly-poly fish heads okay we
got like congealed meat we got like so
much meat over $20 that's the problem
here the problem isn't scarcity the
problem is inflation and speculation
brought on by the capitalist class the
fruit section I learned this in camp
finally found my shampoo and conditioner
took me like a while to do that because
there are so many varieties
damn you Maduro my video was a response
to US media which was embedded with the
Venezuelan opposition and with USAID
right now on the Colombian border in
cucuta and doing this humanitarian
intervention propaganda show where
they're actually claiming that there is
no there are no basic goods in Venezuela
at all and I was showing that in a
fairly upscale neighborhood in Caracas
the supermarket looks just like the
supermarket's in my hometown of
Washington DC I can also tell you that I
was out today in some of the poorer
areas of Caracas and I actually
encountered the vice president of
Venezuela del Cielo Rodriguez and the
mayor of Caracas Erika Farias at
open-air food markets around the city
where food is being distributed
basically for free to the poor and
working-class communities the problem
here is with speculation there are high
prices on foods and random situations so
that has to do with actually the kind of
capitalist class here that supports the
opposition us sanctions are actually
allowing them to hoard Goods and to make
maximum profit and those so that's the
irony here is that many of the
supporters of the opposition and the big
business forces behind the opposition
are actually cashing in on the economic
crisis
you